okay guys it's your boy psychobabble um
we are gonna do this one somebody else's
defeat the bully among riding in a
[ __ ] that's very sad
the traitors are small small human being
if you guys don't know so I'll check it
out okay just [ __ ] who's again a very
small person hiding it within the
southern shop a former sandbox symbiotic
relationship with a bully Hmong fight it
my thought is that where is this dude
all the way over there holy God okay
okay so a little s-video to all of you
saw it we got this super dope gun I
don't know what's gonna happen with
these
do all the enemies respond every time Oh
CNA Jess yet holy crap is powerful are
they also then I guess Oh nope
definitely not
I say where I can get the crouching to
lock gameplay the hell is that
a little bit oh crap what's he shooting
at
okay let's see
- no doubt
oh do these things reopen again right
then don't ever touch us
I don't know let's open this app I can't
whoa barely work why didn't like the
other one fly up in the air
nobody knows fit that guy and I really
expected a will eat it out guys go kill
this magic you know she's like friends
that mess was come with it oh that's a
nice can well is this it
I got no shield right now but that's
okay cuz I'm about that turn one I'm
happy
one eight eight tell us where Jesus so
these are all equipped it I don't
anything else well our friend of a
circuit mode okay my she's on map okay
not that far
holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] those dopes
that is a really cool feature holy God
you're like basically invincible
especially with the freedom sniper rifle
yeah sir
and I think that where the tech is you
shoot at them
okay I can't take this
it's a point of these things they're
just Sekhmet money
anybody Howser nobody in this whole
place
[Music]
[ __ ] it bighead sit
can't tell
that's see anyone yet
see it takes like forever without open
him so I just like to go around and open
them up anyway sorry I've been a little
quiet for less than five minutes just
really kind of just like perplexed so I
hope you have this a whole town with no
one in there yeah I saw something
dad dad did I forget to shout like where
does it's in right
holy thick five minutes way do I lose
any money
Oh 62 bucks
where is he
to hell
oh sorry gonna cough some over there
shooting me
no okay
you go upstairs I guess that
holy God this prep this what is so
powerful okay I'll do this let's get
ready or is yet my shield is recharged
at bro
Rep come on he's almost at a little
shotgun Mitch it makes your writing a
little lo mo oh [ __ ] [ __ ] comprar any
some shell
let me just get the shield open up again
where's the giant [ __ ]
supposedly the midgets over here
somewhere
anyways at the top
yeah
[Applause]
level up how do I get a another one
okay no okay so the bully monger guys
should be over here somewhere he's over
here
[Applause]
that [ __ ] your stupid magic oh crap I'll
get him I'll get him okay I gotta get
out of here dude okay that was that let
me go turn in uh anyway that's a really
interesting mission is that a hard
mission I can't tell guess so
there's no way I guess I might know hard
as you can't just like some type the
dude yeah this is I have to go through
that whole ordeal I know crap how do I
get back
oh yeah that's rich thing
ma'am I guess a freezin well I have so
much loot I saw to just jump by the hole
now
man a lot action Jesus Pilate do
headshots like sorry this is a point if
you're like looking for something a
house but like I like Dan shots you know
like don't be mad just like how I hope I
get you so much your headshots you know
like thank God I have a fast job I'll
think brace on like you know walk
upright ten days straight okay can i
well cause this like I said
you know I do is they almost dead you
know I got so many cats
oh my god
okay yeah anyway that's on this like and
give it a six out of ten I'm at a bad my
shed just like nothing no no well I
guess anyways I hope y'all enjoyed where
is this dude suit their award is don't
get that no mom a little tough okay
thanks it Watson yell thank you